[Music]
you are multi-talented you are at you
are so funny you're such a terrific
actor and you're also you're a great
jazz singer I've listened to you sing
jazz I'm last time you I think you were
on the show you sang some David Bowie
for us which was really great we sang
together it wasn't just me you sang a
bass line like you he can sing yeah I'm
surprised you're also like a triple
threat it was it was a lot it was a lot
of fun and you know I know I don't know
what you're into now like what kind of
one jazz singing a know if you want to
do anything tonight any kind of jazz
absolutely okay you're gonna join me
because I think you're ready to go to
the next level you take a baseline
before so now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna scat scat yeah that's a kind
of jazz singing that a lot of us use
when we forget the words to song so so
no words just make up noises and sounds
and try and be yeah like that and it's
called scat singing I know somewhere in
Germany there's a porn producer going
huh yeah let's try this out right now
the band will help us out and we'll do
it together and I'll try not I'll try
and keep up with you you you can do it
you know you can hey cats about 12 bar
blues b-flat medium swing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you